hello folks
welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
and today we're going to be doing more
or less what we've done lately and
that's
i'm going to divide the lecture in three
parts
first part i'm going to be uh dealing
with extinction
extinction of man second part i'll be
doing
quantum computers so if you're
interested in
quantum computing now stick around might
learn something
and finally i'm going to answer
questions that people ask throughout the
week
okay uh in fact i'm going to start with
a question uh
someone just asked because it sets the
tone
in a certain way right says uh
does the world really need saving
does the world need saving in other
words if
humans are going to become extinct maybe
we can do something about it maybe it'll
never happen maybe it's going to be so
far
out into the future that none of us need
to worry
you know there's different possibilities
and this fellow says
does the world need saving
the answer is that it's irrelevant
whether the world needs saving
whether we can save it whether we should
save it
we can't do anything about extinction
mother nature
so to speak programs the
extinction of a species when she spawns
it
okay so uh every species
will eventually go extinct some sooner
than others but
they all go extinct and whatever kills
them
i'm saying has to do with the vitals
some people think that
humans are not animals
well some of us are but uh
people have this notion that because we
have intelligence
right that we're not really animals that
we are so different than the rest of the
animal kingdom
that for all practical purposes we are
not
animals that's that's their uh
reasoning and i'm saying that
uh we got to revise that very carefully
we are animals and what
proves it what what defines us as
animals what puts us in that category
are what i call the vitals okay we
breathe
we eat we drink we sleep we have sex not
maybe not all animals have sex i think
they all do in one way or another
even plants have sex we are living
entities and as living entities uh
we kind of categorize the living
entities
we're not rocks or minerals we're not
plants we're not
trees or flowers we belong in the animal
kingdom
there is no other kingdom other than
those
so so maybe anaerobic uh systems
whatever but
we are living entities and within that
we fit within the animal kingdoms more
specifically they put us within the
mammal kingdom okay or order or whatever
um so we are animals we are mammals okay
and what puts us there are the vitals
and what i'm saying is mother nature
produces extinction through the vitals
she she attacks one of those or she
programs one of those to get rid of us
not only us but any any species for that
matter
so yeah uh that's where we have to set
our eyes on
and people you know in the
paleontologists and so on
geneticists they came up with all these
theories for extinction
of animals in the past involving
volcanoes
involving asteroids comets uh
supernovas big catastrophic events
that's all they could think about
and no i'm saying it all happens through
the vitals
and we can't do anything about the
vitals we must eat we must drink
you know uh i don't know if we have to
have sex if we we might have to sleep
uh i think we do i don't think you can
live without sleeping okay but that's
debatable under some you know some
people might debate that
i think what's beyond debate is you need
to eat eat and drink
those are the most fundamental uh
behaviors habits that all
oh absolutely all living entities have
plants have them
animals have them we all have those two
vitals we all need those two vibes we
need to eat and drink
and so i'm saying those are the two that
mother nature uses to get rid of
something happens to our eating
something happens to a drinking
air we can say we can take for granted i
mean nobody has bottled air yet so i
don't think
it's going to come through the air okay
it's not through the airwaves okay
okay so let's get on with the first
issue that someone raised
okay it's uh related to extinction again
and so uh this person asks the following
he says uh how can a concept
money cause an object to uh go extinct
uh people produce things all the time
for no money we only use the concept of
money to make trade more
efficient okay hate on money
all you want i'm not hating money i love
money
just as much as anyone else i need it
the
guy says do we need uh exchange i don't
know about extinction but we need to do
something about money
uh its uh ending will not cause the
extinction of man
the sun will um that means that
they say that the sun is gonna last
another
five billion years it's been around for
five billion it's gonna last another
five billion they say it's at
it's halfway mark uh so you're saying
we're gonna live another five billion
years
as a species on this planet we lived
only
what maybe two hundred three hundred
thousand years
and now we're going to live five billion
more years or
five billion years total uh
that's kind of weird to think that we're
going to live that long i mean for all
practical purposes that's an eternity
and we're going to be on this little
planet which we can't get out of we
cannot
go out of the solar system we cannot uh
conquer colonize another star system
the nearest star system for example
alpha centauri
centauri has three stars alpha beta and
proxima
proxima's the nearest star they say that
beta centauri
is the most similar to the sun so let's
assume
beta is the the proper candidate uh
maybe it's got some
earth-like planet orbiting around it are
we ever going to go to beta
and i'm saying no we have no chance
whatsoever of traveling
to the nearest star alive
okay i'll clarify that alive okay we're
not gonna make it there alive even if we
do
this uh intergenerational uh
traveling on a taurus a spinning taurus
anyway you
twist and turn it we're never going to
make it to the nearest star
okay and of course you would have to use
some
magical stuff like general relativity
you know going through the fourth
dimension and that kind of thing
uh to say that uh how how to get there
you know in a jiffy
okay we make it through the through the
time dimension
it's got to be some weird thing like
that you can't do it normally you can't
do it
with humans you know getting on a ship
and going out there no way
know how so we're never going to get go
out of the solar system
i doubt we'll ever get even to mars we
might make it to mars
there's there's a chance there but for
what for colonization are we gonna
evacuate all the prisons and move all
the prisoners out there
and say look uh this is our outpost the
outpost
prison you guys are gonna live in mars
from now on
uh no uh we're never gonna colonize mars
if anything we visit it could be it
could happen it might
but we're not gonna settle and we're
gonna die here on earth
and so are we gonna live for five
billion years here on this little planet
with uh population decreasing uh as
population birth rate sorry
decreasing to a point where even in this
century we're gonna
reach zero population growth uh we're
not going to expand
uh globally in our population
and we're going to be doing this uh
we're going to stay like that for 5
billion years
and it's kind of weird that you would
think that way so
um what do i answer well he says uh how
can a concept money
cause an object to go extinct
well uh what causes you to go extinct is
food
not the concept we're talking about real
stuff the stuff you put in your mouth
goes through your stomach
and out the other end and we're talking
about that kind of stuff
so it's stuff that's going to kill us
because if you don't have that
you don't have something to eat or drink
for that matter
uh not to mention air but we're going to
discount air
if you can't eat or drink you are going
to die and if the whole population on
earth
all 8 billion of us can't eat or drink
for whatever reason okay we die because
something
physical did not enter our bodies turns
out that
we produce it with money which is a
concept
so our mere existence
our survival whatever you want to call
it our extinction
all depends on food
which is standing on a concept which is
built
or constructed upon a concept
makes you kind of wonder about that you
know
it it already the production of all this
and the distribution of food relies on a
concept
and let me give you uh for instance here
i um
uh well let me give you first a little
story
before i go into this one um
you talk about concepts okay you say
well
you are am i saying that a concept
maintains us alive and if the concept
disappears we disappear
well concepts have a way of
materializing
you know you have debt okay you owe the
bank money you know the credit card
company you owe the
mortgage company whoever your money
right
it's a concept here's this concept
running around
just a number out there you receive a
bill every
month maybe you don't even receive a
paper you see it on the internet it's a
number
and because of that concept you jump up
and down
you get a second job uh maybe you marry
so that you pull your
resources together with your wife uh you
know you do whatever
you need to do you jump around
because of this concept this that this
number that's in a computer
you know it's got consequences and
because of those consequences that you
foresee coming
if you default on your payments or
whatever
you're jumping around you're standing on
your head you're getting a second job
you you know you do whatever's near
maybe you rob a bank maybe you kill
someone and steal from them
maybe you kill your grandfather so you
can inherit
you do all these things for this concept
now isn't that scary a concept is
governing use
it's the remote control that moves you
around
so weird but here this is what i wanted
to show you okay
here's a bridge okay and you're going to
construct it up in the air
okay it's gazillions of miles above the
earth right you're going to construct
this
bridge and you put it over the concept
mass mass is holding the bridge up
above the clouds uh would you walk on
that bridge
i mean it's sitting it's its foundations
are sitting on mass
kind of scary isn't that uh and here's
our situation today okay
we have uh food all these items of food
and they're real and are sitting on this
concept we call
money now now money there i made it
tangible you know bills
but really today it's almost all
abstract it's just a number in a
computer that's
that's what 99 of the money is out there
it's just a bunch of numbers in a
computer
and let's hope no hacker gets to that
and wipes all the accounts on earth
you know from from the record because i
don't know what we all would do if
someone just goes in there and goes blip
turns everything to zero which is
uh what some hackers might try to do
okay and yeah we need to fill our
bellies with all this food and
all this food just sits on money and it
only gets produced
and distributed because of money so yeah
in in a way you're saying uh a concept
kills us
yeah indirectly because the concept
produces the
object okay and right now maybe
in advanced nations 80 85 of
those economies are all services
a lot of them lately you know becoming
internet services you know a computer
guy
he does programming or he creates an ad
or does commercialism or
or sells information or whatever you
know
it's all a concept and 85
of that are services that we have in our
economy
both in labor and in
gdp as a percentage of gdp
and that produces the very little
1 of agriculture
which keeps us all alive because it
produces and distributes the vitals
that we need to stay alive one more day
now isn't that that you you should sit
back
and think for a minute you know the
situation here this is a little
different than it was uh 50 000 years
ago
where uh you know we went out into the
uh planes saw
mammoth or whatever just killed it you
know through a lance kill it
we had food for a week for the whole
clan
we were in direct contact with the food
and the food
outnumbered us naturally mother nature
says you know we're gonna produce
all these buffaloes all these uh
mammoths whatever we had out there you
know
that we hunted uh and it produced
tons of it so there was a maybe a ten to
one relationship
between um the
amount of food usually herbivores
with respect to the apex predators
which was us that's a different story
than
what we have today today food has become
a goldilocks type commodity okay
it's just right now what do i mean by
that i mean that
you can't produce too much of it you
know because if you do
well uh the price goes down you know
it's cheap and
maybe not everybody wants it like you
know you have an apple orchard
in california so you hire a bunch of
mexicans you know they cross the borders
they're wet
backs okay you pay them i don't know
five bucks an hour
and you tell them go go pull all my
apples from every single tree
okay so you pull them all out you paid
these guys to do that
okay and now you put it on the market
turns out they only buy you know the
public out there only buys maybe
20 of them most people maybe don't want
apples or they eat something else
and so you only sell 20 of your apples
so why did you produce a hundred percent
of your apples
paying all these guys more time than
necessary to pull them off the trees
and then distribute them you know take
them through the
to the uh distributor in other words you
you have to ship them out right
box them maybe whatever why did you do
all that work
pay all this money when they only bought
20 percent of your
of your product and um
and very cheap because you know there
were so many apples that you know they
were 10 cents apiece
i think what you would like to do is pay
your your workers a little less
a lot less if you can have them work
less hours
pull only 20 of your apples out so that
you
you know once you did your market you
study in in the market of how much
apples you really or uh
you know uh realistically plan to sell
uh you pull only 20 of your apples out
that's what you put on the market that's
what you sell
and you sell them not at 10 cents a
piece you sell them at maybe a dollar or
whatever a piece
that's the way it's done and so you know
we produce uh food in that way we
produce
only so much food on earth we could
produce a lot more if we wanted to
but what would we do with the excess so
what we do is we produce
enough food that we know is going to be
bought out there and that's a function
directly of population we don't produce
twice as much food as we produce today
because
we only have 8 billion people so we
don't produce food for 16 billion people
because for one we're doing overwork
that you know and
most of that product will go extinct
sit on the shelves and buy get rotten uh
and the other one is going to pull the
price down so it's the supply and demand
per standard
supply and demand curve and so yeah
goldilocks
food is a goldilocks type of commodity
produce just
enough of what you need to feed the
populations
and it's a peg to the population okay
so we're not going to produce more than
necessary and
incidentally let me just put this up
here the difference between
rich and the wealthy okay you have a
rich person and you have a wealthy
person
if you look up these two words are
synonyms well you know i'm
for many years i've proposed a
difference between these two words
okay and so here it is rich guy is a guy
who has money
who has liquidity wealthy is a person
who has
things now you can sell things and
become rich
and you can buy things and become
wealthy okay so you can
there's a cross uh between those but i
want to keep those two words separately
rich
it's a guy who has money and wealthy is
a guy who has
has things and you can imagine what that
has to do with our uh extinction theory
okay uh we have the rich and the wealthy
you could be rich
and not have a single carrot to eat
and so you're not wealthy okay
now maybe you say well i can buy one
well that's if the guy who has the
carrot
is willing to sell you his carrot for
your million dollars which are worthless
pieces of paper or maybe just a number
in a computer
so you say i'm going to transfer a
million dollars to you well you said
well that's just a number
i don't care for that i'm going to stay
with my carrot
okay so uh keep all this
in mind factor it into your notions of
extinction and here's the bottom line
okay this is the future the haves versus
the have
nots okay this is what it is the haves
are going to be the people
who have food and have nots
uh will be people who don't have food
and they're known as the dead okay
so uh that's my take on that
take it as far as you want okay but
that's the way i look at it
okay another issue along the same lines
okay follow us
last last time let me get this thing up
here hold it
give me a second
okay uh he said um
said i don't follow the causal chain of
your theory of man's extinction
how does decreasing genetic diversity
and population
lead man through his own policies to
destroy his
economy okay and that's
that's a the bottom line that is the
the question okay it is so that's the
question we try to answer here okay
so um how do you look at this
okay let me show you an outline of
the mechanism now there's two mechanisms
and they should not be confused okay the
first mechanism
is what i call the mechanism of a
background extinction
background extinction is when one
species all by itself
disappears okay goes extinct
the other one is the mass extinction and
that's when
many species maybe a whole order okay
what i call an entire food chain that
disappears
and the mechanisms behind each one of
these
is different okay so that's the first
thing i want to mention
just overall then the other thing you
need to know is that the
mass extinction is founded upon the
mechanism
of the background extinction which is
what this gentleman
put here okay he says look we have this
uh
um production this population issue
how did what how does that relate to the
mass extinct how do we time together
so that's where we're headed here okay
here's the uh
mechanism okay and again this is just an
outline just so you can see the
train of thought okay on the left
we have the background extinction and
these involve biological factors
uh typically what i call the vitals
okay and here we have the first one uh
we're gonna have in the case of man okay
i'm applying this to man but this
applies really to any species
it happens when uh many individuals of a
given species
develop in a given region uh
under in our man in our human society we
call it
cities population explosion you know
uh metropolitan area et cetera everybody
moves there
we call that the transition it's a
process where people move from the
country
to the city okay and this was a
predictable unavoidable transition
or phenomenon there was no way we could
have avoided
eventually moving to the cities
as intelligent as we are as smart as we
are as
we can foresee the future we could not
have avoided this
moving to the cities and this uh
triggered what we call density dependent
birth rates
when we move to the cities we stop
having children okay
we stop having children for social
cultural
economics several reasons okay and i'm
not going to go into detail here
i'm just saying that we get into density
dependent birth rates that means
that we stop having children at the same
rate that we had in the country
and uh the total population and i'm
talking about global population here
starts um approaching uh you know
grows asymptotically okay it approaches
a plateau
okay so uh population grows
asymptotically
and um what we have we have
superimposed upon that we have thousands
of years of inbreeding
we have been having sex and children
with each other
and we've been doing that for maybe 200
300 000 years more or less
so because of doing that we have lost
our genetic diversity
we have little genetic diversity in in
the human race
a chinese man even though he's got
slanted eyes and he's different than the
black man of africa and different than
a russian who is white and so on we're
all we all look
differently superficially but our
genetics
are almost identical we are all clones
of each other
in so many other respects especially
what concerns
diseases our defenses against diseases
that uh we can say that all humans are
essentially clones today
all eight billion of us and we descended
from the
uh the two and a half billion people
that
existed when i was born that came out of
the 1 billion people that
were here maybe in 1820 or thereabouts
we descend from the 300 million that
came out of the beginning of the
christian era
okay and so on and so forth we all come
from a small
group of people and in fact it's a
percentage of those people because not
all
people not all couples had children so
we've lost our genetic diversity
pretty much and we also get this
population pyramid over
term because our population grows
asymptotically that means that
we uh we get older we have more uh old
people in our
population mix and fewer younger
people okay and so that's also part of
the process
this is these are the factors that cause
a background extinction
and a lot of this has to do with the
fact that you know a species
goes through this process of uh founders
effect followed by
uh population crashes you know where
a disease war whatever comes in our way
uh
kills many of us and those who survive
you know they produce the next
generation of humans and what we're
doing
essentially is whittling out our
diversity our genetic diversity
okay that's the process for our
background extinction in in a nutshell
that's the outline
when we move to the right there we see
the mass extinction and this has to do
with
economic factors now what happens here
we have decreasing demand
because we have fewer what's happening
on the left we have fewer people
in other words we're producing fewer
people meaning we're producing
little demand or less demand for the
future we're gonna have fewer
proportionately fewer grandchildren than
uh
our great grandfathers had okay so
that's the first issue
and what is population population is
demand and demand is population
okay so corporations expect more sales
next year
they they hope to have more profits what
is uh more profits what is more sales
it's demand what is demand population
okay so uh but on top of that we we
throw efficiency we're so smart
that we're killing ourselves we're we're
creating all these machines
and we're doing innovation in the
workforce where we introduce
better ways of doing things faster ways
and so we get rid of
people that we don't need we make our
businesses more cost effective okay
and this drives the proletarians to live
on subsistence wages
uh and you know on top of that you can
put that
what's there on the next the last line
which is unemployment and welfare you
got to keep these people
uh alive still somehow so those that
work maintain those that don't work and
that's called welfare
so we introduce welfare measures or
reduce
the salaries of the proletarian so that
they're barely at the
minimum wage or slightly above okay
and on top of that we have you know the
fact that we lose real value of the
money i put the dollar sign there but
i mean money okay we have the government
uh you know the evaluation because of
debt and so they create money and that
devalues the
money as well okay uh we have the
bankers casino derivatives they play
around with your money
okay so you give them money and say
please please bet i'm number five at the
roulette
okay and that's what the bankers do they
invested in derivatives what are
derivatives
well a bunch of concepts just a a market
out there where people just believe that
things are going to get
more expensive in the future or cost
more and so they
invest in these things okay we have
service economy manufacturing
and agriculture what happens the service
economy has
trumped manufacturing agriculture it's
squeezing it out of gdp and out of labor
we're all becoming service providers
okay so
that's also happening there and then
when i covered unemployment and welfare
again where i i say that services is
unemployment it's a different it's
mass unemployment you are unemployed if
you're in the service economy
and that's 85 of some of these advanced
nations economies
and uh and then yeah we don't have real
global growth
okay so that's in a nutshell what i'm
saying is
is the process that leads from
population
to the mass extinction okay
now in the case of the animals okay i'm
sorry yeah in the case of the animals in
the past the extinctions in the past
how did that happen did they do it with
money was there money involved was there
a transaction
trade no uh we're one of the few animals
in the
world that trades okay we don't do
trading
animals don't do trading we do we're a
special type of animal that's that's the
way we produce our goods and
produce eight billion people thanks that
we can to the fact that we can support
them we can support them why because we
can produce
all this thanks to money that's our
system
okay lion doesn't use that system lion
uses his legs
that's his system and his mouth okay
that's his system
he can live with that we can't live with
that we we don't hunt with our mouths
anymore we don't do it with our feet
we're slow animals we don't have big
teeth
no we do it a different way we do it the
monkey way we
uh you know corral animals and kill them
at our leisure and we corral plants
grow them at our leisure and then kill
them as well remember
plants are living entities so for those
vegetarians and
vegans and whatever uh yeah you're
killing
plants you're murdering now you're
ripping
the skin of a banana little banana says
oh please don't kill me yo
um you're you're sir
and you say i'm gonna rip your skin i'm
gonna skin you alive
skins the banana goes
goes the banana yeah you're killing
something that's living no matter how
you look at it okay
so we all kill things you must kill to
live
that's that's that's how mother nature
planned it okay
god or father universe whoever yeah
okay so what's the deal with uh with
population well this is
the relationship maybe with uh our
artificial economy as i call it
okay and population they mo
more or less go together okay and at
some point we're going to reach a
maximum population
which means we're going to reach a
maximum uh
growth in global economics
in other words we cannot continue
growing forever okay
uh we cannot have the economy of 16
billion people
for only 8 billion people okay
the economy is proportional to
population
okay so that's one issue and uh
you know that takes us back to um
let me show you this first okay so
this is our uh how the population grows
okay typically and you know i was born
in 1952 in
those days it was about two and a half
billion people on earth
and in just what almost 70 years
uh we've become three times as many
we're seven and a half to eight billion
people today
three times as many since i was born
and i like to put my pyramids upside
down because you know i like to show
them
towards the future and the future is
always up you know time has a direction
it goes up
in general relativity and quantum
mechanics
always up okay so there it is and we're
gonna reach maybe nine billion people
maybe we'll never make it that far i
don't think we will uh
and what happens when you know we reach
that plateau
well our economics is going to stop
we're not going to the companies are not
going to be selling
more and more and more as they expect
they can't make projections for the next
you know
five year plans no no such thing because
suddenly you
you know population has come to a stop
and so what happens now well our
economics our global growth
comes to a stop we cannot have
an economy of 16 for 16 billion people
whatever that number is
globally gdp whatever uh for only eight
billion people
or nine billion whatever okay so
these are things you gotta factor okay
uh
you know the macroeconomics is important
in this case
for those who believe in free will free
willy is like
as i call them there is no such thing as
free will you're a human that belongs
in a uh you know us humans were social
animals and you belong to a society
and that society has a certain economics
and yeah you can do your little thing
here and there as long as the global
picture stays
okay and progresses and moves upwards
but if the global system comes to stop
because we've reached maximum population
meaning we meet
maximum economic growth then the free
willy cannot do his little thing out
there because suddenly something
from the outside is imposed upon him
more or less like i explained a minute
ago where you know
you are governed by a concept you have a
debt and you jump
through your butt to try to pay it and
you say but it's just a cons just a
number
why are you so worried why are you
working overtime why are you
robbing the bank and killing your
grandfather to inherit money
you're doing all this for a concept
you're killing your you're murdering
you're stealing
you're working overtime you're you're
doing all these things for a concept
yeah these concepts have an effect over
you because
that's how our economic system works
for humans okay it doesn't work like
that for lions it doesn't work like that
for others you know but it does work for
us like that
okay so yeah concepts just move us
around their little pinky sorry with the
little pinkies
it moves us around everywhere okay
uh moving on here apollo says
oh sorry uh that's the next
uh did one finish here
something went wrong here give me a
second let me get my bearings
oh i see what happened i just wanted to
show this uh the birth
rate i think i showed that okay now
here's another issue the guy
uh asked another fellow asked
and it's uh there is no doubt that the
uh
the corrupt governments are diverting
their lockdown disaster with building
justification for
war with china and russia will there be
a war between the united states and the
other two
superpowers uh we gotta wait and see
don't we we don't know what's gonna
happen
but it could happen and why would it
happen would it happen because
people like to go to war the soldiers
like to kill themselves or kill someone
on the other side
well some of them might do but it all
comes down to economics it has to do
with
interest and you know gaining markets
and
that sort of thing so war is a function
of economics
in fact a lot of people start wars be
even through false flags countries do
uh why because it's profitable
it's got to do all with economics wars
have always been for
economic reasons ultimately there could
have been religious
factors poured in there maybe racial
factors
you can put anything you want in their
countries you know different countries
different people different languages
social reasons
ultimately it was all for influence over
economics it was conquering markets
you stood in the way of the progress of
one economy and they said we won't let
you do that we're gonna send our army
over
that's how it worked uh yes it is true
we will
probably see war in the next six years
okay it will not be just
nukes okay it will be with
bio weapons okay so we have nukes and
bio weapons both
he says humanity will not go extinct
did he say that he's saying we're going
to have we're going to be throwing the
nukes at each other
uh not we're not going to stop there
we're going to use everything at our
disposal
okay so we're gonna throw the bio
weapons because we're not gonna let the
other side win
we have probably weapons enough weapons
on earth to destroy each other
but the guy says even if we go to war
and throw all these things at each other
humanity will not go extinct
for sure we're going to disrupt all
commerce trade
does uh every country have enough
distribution internal distribution
system to be able to feed its
population like overnight like if
war starts tomorrow does every country
have enough food
internally to support its population
will the all these companies that
produce and distribute food and other
objects to
exchange for food right ultimately
will they be able to maintain themselves
without um a world market today
see world war ii even world war one none
of those
were really on a global basis you know
we were not
that interrelated globally today
international uh markets international
commerce is way more developed than it
was in world war one or world war
ii the next war is going to be a little
different
not only will we have nukes and bio
weapons because nobody will want to lose
they're just going to throw the whole
works at everybody else
but it's going to disrupt everything
it's going to disrupt all kinds of
markets
internal and external both
uh no if we have a third world war it's
like uh
i think it was einstein who said um says
i don't know how uh the third world war
will be fought
but the fourth one will be fought with
sticks and stones
and or maybe it was khrushchev who said
i can't remember
someone in the 50s said that okay only
your corrupt governments as they have in
the past
following a cycle that seems to follow
the sun like a flower
uh yeah um
i'm saying that war if war comes
it's going to be a little different this
time around okay
okay another fella i think it's the same
fellow says um
you said that the degeneration will be
the end of us
um no but uh let's continue
i disagree and point to pottinger's cats
as an example
covered that the other day uh i'll
review that
quickly patenters showed a
nutrient-deficient diet led to
disease that compounded from generation
to generation in cats
okay a disease okay he reversed these
diseases in cats with nutrient dense
foods
like uh whole raw milk well that's like
saying uh
i have a disease and i i had a headache
i took an aspirin and
my headache went away that's not a
genetic
issue you haven't shown that and again
proof is in the eye of the beholder
uh people some people criticize
potential
saying that his was unscientific
and you can look that up into wikipedia
there's a couple articles on that
and even potential accepted to a certain
extent that well maybe he
went a little overboard on his
conclusions so
okay yeah whatever but uh i'm looking at
that last statement any degeneration can
be de
uh reversed and i'm saying um
i don't think so okay and here's uh
here's an example i'm just going to give
you a couple examples
degeneration will not be the end of us
first of all okay
i'm saying that economics will be the
end of us
in our case in the case of humans but
let's move on inbreeding would cause
our extinction but fortunately
the way i see it okay the global
economics will collapse
much sooner and spares the agony
of a slow death see
background extinction is very slow it
takes several
decades hundreds of years maybe
thousands of years
and gradually a species disappears
because
their population pyramid overturns their
genetics get wiped out etc
so that takes a long time economics
that's
almost immediate and it's uh especially
in the case of man
we've taken ourselves so much to the
limit that we depend so much on money
now to produce
distributed food that the day that money
disappears that the global economy
collapses meaning money will be no more
meaning we will not accept money from
someone else
in exchange for the only thing of value
which will be food
that's when uh the economy collapses and
that's going to be very quick
it's not going to give you time to react
it's going to be in a matter of days
maybe weeks
that's it and then genetic problems
cannot be reversed
right uh let's find out uh condoms be
reversed
down syndrome or any of those mental is
illnesses
you know can homosexuality be reversed
well some people believe that
it can and it's a social issue that uh
the guy
um was uh educated to be like that maybe
he was mommy's little boy or whatever uh
i have a different opinion i think that
homosexuality is a genetic problem the
person is born that way
can't do anything about it that's my
take on that that's the assumption i
work with okay
uh do we have any cure for muscular
dystrophy or
any of these genetically uh caused
physical uh problems so we have the
mental and the physical
the mental is ultimately a physical one
because it's how the brain is structured
so it also can be called a
physical problem okay it's the uh
organ we have in the head known as the
brain and whoever
suffers from some kind of mental problem
ultimately has
a physical problem as well can we
reverse these if they
are genetically caused in other words if
you're born that way
and my answer is no you cannot reverse
that i don't care what you bombard the
guy with
okay and and then you have deleterious
uh mutations
they decrease fitness of an organism
okay
so um you're not prepared to handle
certain diseases voted yeah this one
wrong
um in fact i knew a girl uh
miriam his name her name was and she
lacked a chromosome she had 22
chromosomes only
terrible stuff and she heard it from her
father who had the same problem
and he didn't find out until he was
later on you know later in life
she didn't find out until i think in her
teens when
her father had the problem and she
missed this chromosome and because of
that
all her muscles were going dead
and she got to a point where she wasn't
able to lift her arms
you know a terrible disease and it's
genetic
now think about it uh she's got all
these muscles in her body
the muscles are built with cells cells
are built with gazillions of
muscles are built with gazillions of
cells gazillions of cells each one is
built with gazillions of molecules
uh dna rna etc
something's wrong in her chromosomes are
they going to remove
a little piece out of there or
put another chromosome in each one
of her molecules in each one of her
cells
to get her to be normal again is that
possible
well you know i don't know uh
maybe in the future after we're all dead
i don't think that's possible you know
it's got to be a very
sophisticated machine you put her in
there and it goes
just bombards her you know machine guns
her with all these chromosomes in the
right place
i don't think so okay anyways uh
i think you cannot reverse anything
that's genetically
has a genetic origin okay
uh next issue moving on here
oh get in here okay uh
lava a lot i wasn't totally serious with
the dino gravity hypothesis i first
heard of it from creationists
i think or electric universe types okay
but i've always liked the idea
well you either like it or you don't
okay it's a black or white issue
if you like it we'll defend it if you
don't you know okay the sheer size of
many dinosaurs
uh does seem almost paranormal to us now
and i like the idea of gravity
fluctuating i thought bill might
appreciate it for at least
being original i had heard already of
the gravity
uh theory as well you know and
you have another one like egg predation
and those get on the wikipedia
you know someone publishes something
maybe saying oh i'm the first one to
come up with this
it's a nonsense theory but they're the
first one to publish
and they get it uh someone mentions it
on the
wikipedia maybe you know on the
extinction list
something or or maybe in some blogs out
there or whatever
uh and and people say well there's all
these theories
no those aren't theories those are
people who just want to get their names
on the books and say i'm the first one
who came up with the gravity theory
or with the egg predation theory
that's nonsense those people don't have
half a brain
okay and so yeah you gotta answer
where the moses are uh they were in the
water
they're not affected by gravity not
nearly as much as we
are uh birds up there you know you had
the uh
pterosaurs uh flying reptiles
they died uh the um
what is it the birds did not many birds
did not
uh so you got to explain that you
explain why some reptiles
died or especially the ones in the water
which
are not affected by gravity nearly as
much as the ones on land so
it's not a theory that you can apply
across the board and if you cannot
it's an invalid theory it's just people
who want to get their names in the books
that's it there's not much more to say
about that than that
and again if you're going to vouch for a
theory even half-assed uh
no problem but then uh go all the way
you know either defend it or say no it's
nonsense and reject
never mention it again hopefully you go
to the
guy the wikipedians take it out of there
take all these theories that uh you know
are cannot be right
and i have no chance whatsoever pull
them out of the books
put the guy's name out of there you know
why i say oh joe blows the
first one who came up with the gravity
theory uh jane
doe was the first one who came up with
uh the
egg predation theory what is that
nonsense
okay uh just wanna make sure people
understand that we
encourage people to do extinction 101
before they do extinction 102.
extinction 101 is animals in the past
actual extinctions that happen if you're
a religious uh
person you may not believe in that if
you're a fundamental christian or
whatever
you may not think that uh animals died
in the past those that we find
in the rock because you don't believe
that those rocks took that much time to
be made by god and that if you find
someone down there well it was just only
3 000 or 4 000 years ago
and that's not a dinosaur it's uh what
is it an elephant that's had arthritis
now you can come up with all kinds of
theories out there and some people don't
believe in that
but for those who are a little more
rational
and they acknowledge
that we find bones
dated to 65 million years ago in the
case of the dinosaurs and that
uh yes it took that long a time for
those mountains to build or for
the material to pile up on top and go
through all this uh
earth activity okay yeah if
if if you understand that then you gotta
explain those bones
you gotta explain how those bones
disappeared
and the main thing here is selectivity
you gotta explain how the dinos
disappeared
the whole order and uh left the mammals
alive you gotta come up with a mechanism
that
kills one what i call food chain you can
call it whatever you want
and leaves another food chain rolling as
if nothing okay
once you've explained the mass
extinction not only of the dinosaurs but
you know of all of them triassic uh
archosaurs the uh permian mammal
like reptiles especially at the end you
know 252 million years ago there were
like two extensions during the
permian uh and then uh or backwards if
you go
even further back like the carboniferous
you explain all those extinctions
all those mass extinctions you gotta
apply the cookie cutter something
happened that happened to all of them
and it's the same thing if you have a
different theory for each one
uh well that's already a big somewhat of
a problem but as long as your theory
can explain within a given extinction
within the carboniferous
or within the permian era right if
you're going to flame within that epa
how the animals on land air and sea
disappeared
more or less at the same time okay
then you got a good clue on
extinction on mass extinction on the
mechanism of mass extinction
and so that's the next question here
that i give us
homework and anyone uh is welcome to do
the homework
and homework is like this it says why
did the founder in the
c's disappear at the same time more or
less maybe a thousand
plus or minus a thousand years whatever
it doesn't matter geologically suddenly
geologically at the same time as the
animals on land
and that if you can figure that out if
you can figure out a mechanism that ties
the animal in the land on land with the
animal
in the seas that died approximately at
the same time
why did that happen at the same time
could it be that they were
all related to some kind of food chain
or maybe
the plants that
they ate started more or less
at the same time in the past well i
don't want to give you any clues but
just uh answer the question the homework
is there for you to
do and you know uh you get a beer
if you figure it out okay
let's move on to the lecture of today
and that's got to do with quantum
computing
quantum computers okay so let's start
here
quantum computer what is this all about
well it must be something important
because this is where we start
all these countries are investing quite
a bit of
money okay in developing quantum
computers
they're investing all kinds of money and
uh
both private and and government it turns
out that these numbers that you see
there that's for private that's what's
out there
uh then you have the other stuff the
secret stuff that governments are doing
in relation to quantum computing but
that doesn't get out there in the press
you know
it's uh held under national security
okay so these are just the outward
numbers
okay you can see uh united states china
and
then you have a whole bunch of countries
that form
especially the european union if you
take all those together
uh just the western part there uh
they're more or less
as big as the united states and china so
there's a heavy investment in quantum
computing okay
and you say why why would anyone want to
do
quantum compute i mean the computer you
have at home
it's known as a classical computer you
have a 19th century computer there okay
you know it's classical and it works
just fine it gives you more or less the
speed
sometimes you get problems yeah i've had
problems i
feel like smashing the pieces uh
but it works okay you know it's good
do i need a a quantum computer and if i
do
why would i need a quantum computer what
is a quantum computer about
what are we doing all that why are these
people who are these private
and the government agency or
organizations
why are they investing in quantum
computer you say what's the future
what do we mean by that what's going on
here okay and so here
is a in a nutshell what this is all
about okay what the quantum computers
are
about and what they do is they're faster
faster
computing okay that's probably the main
point
it just does calculations a lot better
and
so for some businesses or some lines of
work uh it helps like for example it
helps
chemists develop chemical modeling
it creates new materials with program
properties
and then you have high temperature super
conductivity and super fluidity
okay so it's used in in these general
areas those are
any businesses related to this kind of
work uh they would like to have quantum
computing
now does that help you in any way well
other than speed
you know maybe one computer is not for
you
you know i mean yeah i'd love to have a
faster computer that
as soon as i touch that uh key on the
keyboard it
boom it does something already you know
or
has more memory or whatever uh right now
i can live with what i got
more or less i could get maybe a better
computer sure
uh but do i need a quantum computer
super duper computer that you know takes
me
to the other side of the universe and
back in a second
okay maybe i do i don't know maybe it'd
be nice to have we gotta wait to see
until they develop it so uh
what is all this about what is uh what
really the question i wanna answer today
okay because this is what we're about
we're not interested so much in
technology in fact
not at all we're interested in science
here and so
here's the question okay question that
i'm going to try to answer today
so if you came here to know a little bit
of about technology you might be
disappointed okay sorry okay so here it
is this is a question i want to ask
uh or that i'm going to answer today i'm
going to try to answer today
do quantum computers have anything at
all to do with
science this is about science we call it
rational science we want to do science
here
and this uh a question of this issue
came up because a fellow asked about
this
in one of the questions so i turned his
question into
the lecture okay okay so um
what is this quantum computing what what
are we talking about here okay here it
is
in a nutshell okay this is just a a
quick
uh synthesis of what quantum computers
or quantum computer
computing does what we expect from it
quantum computing
is the exploitation of collective
properties of quantum states
you know there's 50 states in the union
i don't know any quantum state but
that's what they're talking about what
are these quantum states what are we
talking about such as
superposition and entanglement
okay so we have superposition and
entanglement these are
two quantum states and what are we going
to do with this well
it's going to take the quantum computer
is going to take advantage of these
properties behaviors okay love it
okay let's find out to perform
computation okay they solve
computational problems
substantially faster than classical
computers
which is what i got i got a 19th century
computer a classical one
okay since quantum came around you know
the
20th century and upwards uh well we have
now quantum computing
okay so um essentially it's going to be
faster
that's the bottom line uh
some line items out there of the economy
and some lines of work they might
require
uh this speed for other reasons that
help them develop more technology
but for me it's or for you it's probably
just going to be speed
right welcome speed no problem at all
but the question is are quantum
computers is quantum
computing a part of science that's the
issue we're going to answer
and here we are talking about two
quantum states of which
quantum computers take advantage which
are entanglement and superposition
so we got to get to the heart of those
we got to get to the bottom line there
okay
here's superposition okay
and then put it up here i can get it
there your superposition
okay and uh you can see what it is and
quantum mechanics can be excited and not
excited at all
both simultaneously
how do you explain that rationally to a
human
that you have this these two states in
one
in one where you can even call it
standing still and moving
can you do that at the same time uh
can god be a concept and an object
at the same time can he have shape and
not have
shape at the same time
how would you understand that and same
thing here i mean here
it's got two superimposed states one in
which
uh you know it's it's got these two
states
these two vibrations simultaneously
how can you explain this
i mean maybe the guy can explain it i
don't know but
i don't know if a rational human can
understand it what is he talking about i
mean this is just a statement
that's just saying it is so well that's
a description you haven't told me
how it does this what is the mechanism
okay so and
this is a superposition okay uh
founded on that before we move on to
entanglement okay
which is the other state that they are
going to take advantage of
we got to understand this notion of the
qubit okay
what the hell is a cubit that's uh along
my line of work i worked in
semiconductors
chips okay not potato chips uh
transistors that sort of thing
semiconductors okay
and this is along the same line they say
there are several types of quantum
computers
quantum computing systems okay and the
most widely used model is the quantum
circuit
okay based on the quantum bit or qubit
okay so this is an important point
that underlies especially the uh
superposition
aspect of quantum mechanics it's known
as the qubit
what is the qubit okay a cubit can be a
one it can be in a one
or zero quantum state
okay uh what is this one or zero
i explained it in the past i'm just
going to go briefly here uh
a transistor is either on or it's off
okay so if it's got for example
more than half a volt it's on if you've
got less than half a volt
uh it's a zero and uh and so you have
all these lines crossing at a transistor
you have maybe
the aluminum bust lines you got the poly
silicon lines crossing them and if they
both carry a voltage it's over 5 volt
half a volt then you have that
transistor turns on if it's less than
that it's a zero
so how can that transistor be both
a zero and a one
this is the question it's mind-boggling
uh are you gonna explain that the
transistors both on and off
at the same time okay
let's continue maybe we find the answer
i don't want to
prejudge they're smarter than me okay
when it is uh okay so it says a cubit
can be in a one or zero quantum state or
in a superposition of the one in zero
states
okay great okay when it is measured
when it is measured it is always a zero
or a one okay only when it's measured
before you measure okay it's going to be
in both quantum states it's so you see
it there at the bottom
under the classical computer the
transistor is either a zero or a one
we're down we can't have it both it's
either zero or the one
but under the quantum computer it's
going to be both
before you measure it before you use it
before you do something with it
it's gonna be in a zero and a one so in
the left it's going to be zero or
one and the right is gonna be a zero and
a one okay
the probability of either outcome
depends on the qubit's quantum state
immediately prior to measurement
or usage or whatever so before you use
it
it's going to be in this zero and one
state okay
[Music]
and so let's get to a little more into
the definition of what a qubit is so
that we understand this
exactly what they want to say they say a
cubit the basic
unit of quantum information and again
it's uh
what they're talking about is a
transistor in in real terms okay that's
what we're talking about
a qubit is a two-state quantum
mechanical system it exhibits the
irrational physical interpretations of
quantum mechanics because it's going to
use
entanglement and it's going to use
superposition which is what we're
covering here
okay in classical mechanics a bit is in
a
in one state or the other but in quantum
mechanics the qubit is allowed to be in
a coherent
superposition of both states
simultaneously
see what these people are saying you get
a zero and a one both at the same time
you have a transistor that is on and off
not or off on and off at the same time
before you measure it okay
my god how do we explain that well
here's the explanation
that the typical explanation for this
phenomenon
and it's known as schrodinger's cat
uh um
analogy i guess that's what they call it
okay here it is
okay and what is it well the cat
before you look peek into the box
because you had uh you know uh some
poison in there in a
while and it turns out that you're gonna
have a hammer break it
and uh this radiation comes out and
kills the cat
but you don't know what's happening in
there because you haven't looked in the
box
it's when you open it when you take the
measurement in other words when you use
your eyes
when you do an experiment you go see and
touch
at the lab that's when you know whether
the cat is
in one or the other state it's either
dead or it's either alive
that's how it comes out of the box okay
but before
you peek into the box to find out what
really happened inside there the cat has
both states he's both dead and he's both
alive
so i always ask well what if we remove
all this other stuff that
killed the cat okay before we peek
inside the box is the cat alive or dead
i just put a cat in a box he's alive
i don't open the box is he alive or dead
in there
and these people say that quantum says
he's both
and that's more or less the big problem
we have here there is no way to
understand this
under any circumstance not not for a
rational human being
now a mathematician he's different i
mean he can understand this stuff but
human beings cannot okay
okay so um how about
entanglement well here's uh one phone on
the internet
prominent guy and he has a little
video there and youtube it says
entanglement the quantum around you
and he says from the start he's gonna
talk about entanglement the first thing
he says i'm not going to be able to
really explain what entanglement is
we don't know what superposition is we
cannot explain it in a rational manner
we have no idea what entanglement is
they cannot explain it in a rational
manner he's telling you he's
he's uh confessing up front he's giving
you the fine print
up front saying oh by the way i cannot
explain entanglement
and you say well why can't he i mean
what is this thing entanglement
okay so let's uh illustrated so we know
what we're talking about what is
entanglement here it is
i've shown this in the past here you
have uh
two atoms or whatever two particles you
can say
they're on opposite sides of the
universe so they're 100 million
kilometers or 100
gazillion kilometers apart and these
people are saying that if one is moving
clockwise the other one
is definitely moving counterclockwise in
the other side of the universe
and if you happen to turn the first one
from clockwise or counterclockwise or
vice versa
the other one moves instantly in the
opposite direction
okay so this is what quantum
entanglement uh
set is about and they say they they have
no explanation for this
and let me tell you why they don't have
an explanation and under the rope model
we can see why
and we can see also the answer of why
this does happen
and here it is okay uh
the one on the top is the quantum
version there's nothing in between the
two particles
so yeah we cannot explain how one
particle influences the other one
instantaneously and what they're saying
is well it doesn't do that really what
it happens is
before you take the measurement before
you take the measurement
we already know we mother nature father
universe god whoever the devil
one of those guys has already determined
that the guy on the other side of the
universe
is opposite to the one on this side of
the universe it's already like that
okay so it doesn't matter if your
particle is moving clockwise or
counterclockwise
we know already through quantum because
father universe determines so
that the other one is in the opposite
direction the the one is spinning in the
opposite direction
okay and so when you take the
measurement you know
not that something happened
instantaneously across the universe but
you know that the other one is already
moving in the opposite direction
simply because it is so
okay under the rope model is very simple
you know a rope can spin in one
direction clockwise
or counterclockwise if it's spinning
clockwise
from your end from the other guy's end
it better
had better be spinning counter clockwise
see how easy it was uh yeah you have to
have a mediator
to explain it rationally and uh you know
i
have always had my rope and i'm saying
let's see if i can do this right
uh for you it's moving i think it's
moving clockwise because for me it's
moving counterclockwise
and if i move yours counterclockwise
okay mine is now moving clockwise
so a rope can only move in one direction
or the other one
direction um and you say well can it do
instantaneously isn't there like uh
you know i throw my side of the rope
until that uh
signal reaches you is it still spinning
on your side
in the same direction as mine well uh
it's a little more complicated than that
you have ropes electromagnetic ropes
that are
uh tied from the andromeda galaxy to
0.2 to 2.3 million year light years
away and those are spinning let's say
they're spinning clockwise okay
that rope is still spinning clockwise
and when you measure the questions are
you measuring a single rope
okay are you are you affecting that rope
or is that one just crossing by and
going to another star somewhere
far away so the fact that you can
tune into that because that rope
happened to cross your
atom and you happen to measure and
you're doing clockwise on that
is that the same rope you measured the
next second when you take a measurement
again especially when the earth is
moving around the sun and all the atoms
in the universe are moving everywhere
so it's a little more complicated than
that until
until we uh
try to explain the phenomena and we try
to simply state that oh it does so like
they do so in quantum we don't have an
answer to that question the only way we
can do it is we
analyze what we're doing in the lab and
we can't do that by seeing and touching
because we can't see or touch
the mediator of light we can barely
handle one atom at a time which these
people many times claim
the question is whether that is so are
they doing that can they see an atom
they can't see an atom how do they know
they're handling one at a time is this
just
their theory their conclusion their
inference
okay are they just concluding this
so there's a lot involved in that and
it's got to be done with rational people
sitting down and
exchanging ideas how uh entanglement is
happening
but at least they have a starting point
which is you know a rope can only turn
clockwise or counterclockwise that's it
and then we have to figure out which
rope we're measuring at which time and
whether everything moved in between
okay are we measuring the same rope okay
and then yeah a lot of the ropes that
crisscross an atom
let alone the universe but an atom um
they're spinning in every direction
possible because you have
ropes that are counterclockwise ropes
that are clockwise
that are just going through an atom from
a faraway star to another faraway star
so you got to look at what you're really
doing what you're measuring if people
measure and they don't even know what
they're measuring because they can't see
or
touch the thing and they say oh we've
reached this conclusion
yeah that's based on the particle
hypothesis and of course they can't
explain it with a particle hypothesis so
what does this guy say well i cannot
explain
entanglement well if you cannot explain
entanglement
you're not a scientist because what is
science okay
or for that matter of superposition you
cannot explain superposition
in a rational manner but you got a
problem because what is science in here
we have it
we can put this thing up there here it
is science
a systematic enterprise that builds and
organizes knowledge
and this is their definition not mine by
the way i don't
subscribe to this definition it's got
too many problems but you know
we're using their own definitions here
to find out if
under their definition quantum computing
qubit entanglement superposition if
those qualify as scientific
behaviors or explanations or whatever
and says that builds and organizes
knowledge in the form of what
testable explanations
and predictions uh about the universe
and so if if they cannot explain in a
rational manner
how can they test the explanation
what they're testing is the description
they're describing something
but they're not explaining it and so
no entanglement and superposition which
underlie the qubit okay which underlies
the
quantum computing uh world
is not a scientific uh field
anyone who gets into that is a
technologist not a scientist
and there you see technology what is
scientology again their definition
the sum of techniques skills methods and
processes
used in the production of goods and or
services or in the accomplishment
of objectives okay we define it a little
differently we say that
[Music]
technology is developing gadgets by
trial and error
science is something else what is
science
let's find out and we'll find out in our
conclusions here
science is explanations okay and here it
is
okay these are my conclusions quantum
computing has to do solely with
technology
okay essentially faster computing that's
it
and a marketable word quantum is
inserted
to solve the concept okay so they say oh
it's not just a computer
it's quantum computing and they say oh a
lot of people out there will say
oh the scientists have
proven quantum and how do you know well
you wouldn't have a computer if it
weren't for quantum
and for sure you wouldn't have a quantum
computer if it weren't for quantum
and no they're not talking about science
they're not talking about explanations
they're talking about technology
which has absolutely nothing to do with
science
why because science is explanations
and technology is developing gadgets by
trial and error
okay so if you develop a gadget uh you
know in your lab
yeah you don't have to know how it works
really or you know the
underlying causes or or mechanisms of
the invisible
stuff that underlies it like you know
magnetism or
electricity you don't have to understand
the true genuine
mechanism that underlies light gravity
electricity magnetism you don't have to
understand that you can develop the
gadget because
you have to do something that that is
handled by touch
which is what technology deals with
technology deals with the see and touch
science deals with the mind with
explaining rationally
that's where the difference is okay so
quantum has no rational explanations
physical interpretations four way for
entanglement superposition decoherence
qubit
none of that they don't have a rational
explanation they have descriptions
and they tell you upfront we cannot
explain it we have no physical
interpretation that you can understand
we have we cannot rationalize it so
they're not doing
science if they cannot rationalize it
they are doing descriptions they're
doing technology but they're not doing
science
and so there's uh yeah the conclusion
really therefore is quantum computing
has nothing at all to do with science
and
anyone working in the development of
quantum computers
computing quantum computing is not
a scientist
okay so for those
people who think that these people are
scientists no don't call them scientists
call them technologists or whatever you
want to call them
okay let's get down to the questions
that people ask this week
okay we have a couple of them here first
one uh
foul says what is the origin of the word
science
and in what sense is it used first time
was it or was it used the first time
someone asked a question along the same
line so i'll address these two gentlemen
together
okay fella asked a similar question he
says
it says philosophy natural philosophy is
the root
of rational explanations which is the
business end of rational science
our line here they are to channel which
is composed of a set of facts or
assumptions
what are your philosophical roots okay
so the questions here have to do with
science
and uh with you know what is science the
definition of science what is our notion
of science
and of philosophy as well because
science
under our definition at least includes
philosophy
philosophy is a branch of science under
our notion of science
out of this channel okay so let's get
that straight up front
so here are the answers to this first
one is that
let's put it over here first one is this
notion of
natural philosophy and the answer to
that for
first part is that natural philosophy
died
you can see in the 19th century okay
they after that they started calling it
science because they developed all these
line items within the world of natural
philosophy
so the term national natural philosophy
died down and only and today is used
only by um
dissidents who cling on to the past and
they say oh natural philosophy
uh you know isaac newton he called his
book you know
natural philosophy and so on yeah this
notion of natural philosophy came
all the way from the greeks and it was
heavily used in the
16th and 17th century 18th century
especially and then it started dying in
the 19th century
and here's a summary of that natural
philosophy or philosophy of nature
was the philosophical study of nature
and the physical universe that was
dominant before the development of
modern science 19th century which we say
is not modern science it's also religion
it's a different branch of religion why
because modern so-called
science is mathematics mathematical
physics
and that has to do with belief with
experiments
with predictions with stuff that has
nothing at all to do with science
science is explanations that's the
difference
okay so these people are not scientists
very few people in the world today are
scientists
who are the scientists those who can
explain something
now those you can call scientists but
those who just do a description
especially they're not scientists
especially the people in quantum
mechanics that
describe and they say oh cubit oh
entanglement oh superposition and you
say okay what's the cause how did it
happen
oh we cannot explain it but but we can
use it to develop computers
and we call those quantum computers
entanglement computers
uh the coherent pro computers
what are they going to call them it was
in the 19th century that the concept of
science received its modern shape
with new titles emerging such as biology
physics physicist etc okay
among other technical fields and titles
institutions and communities were
founded
and unprecedented applications too and
interactions with
other aspects of society and culture
occurred
okay so yeah we should not use the term
natural philosophy anymore usually it's
dissidents people who
want to fight against the establishment
they want to bring back
newton and say well he called it natural
philosophy
yeah yeah you're using a term that's not
only old-fashioned but it does not apply
science is fine but we need to define
science and then we
need to define the branches of science
and that's essentially what the first
guy asks what is science where did this
come from okay
okay so let's move on here and here we
have it
okay these are the definitions we have
today
and not one of them passes the test of
science
okay not one of these is a scientific
definition
these are taken out of the wikipedia but
essentially more or less everybody
defines these things in the same
way science a systematic enterprise that
builds and organizes knowledge
now science doesn't deal with knowledge
at all but that's what science means the
word science
stands for knowledge okay
was the word that the romans used so
that was the origin of that word
and it's got to do with the word
knowledge and the problem there is that
no one's ever defined the word knowledge
no one knows what the word
knowledge means today in fact uh
we still are using variations of plato's
definition of the word knowledge which
is
justified true belief
now they just believe if you know
something
it means you believe something and plato
just
added in there that it's different than
believe because you truly believe
that it's true so uh
you might believe that you know that god
is here and so that's your
knowledge your knowledge of god and
another guy might say that no
uh there is no such thing as god and so
they have
they have two different knowledges they
have two different beliefs
that's why we don't use the word
knowledge and science and even though
the word science derives from the word
knowledge
science true genuine knowledge that
science has nothing to do with knowledge
that's where everyone from the greeks
using natural philosophy
all the way to the word science that
they use today none of them
ever did science science is something
else science is explaining something
why because it's objective you give an
objective explanation
for the purposes of physics we're
talking about
causes and mechanisms you deal with
objects there
you explain something rationally to
someone and say look this is the
mechanism
that i propose that this is what's
happening in this invisible
intangible world of mother natures the
person understands your explanation
your mechanism we're done we're through
with science
now it continues is belief knowledge
justified true belief
the old-fashioned knowledge science and
the guy says well do you believe
that that's what's happening in this
invisible intangible world that mother
nature runs out there
well if you believe or not that's your
knowledge
that's your belief that's your version
of science
that's known as religion it's just a
belief
in science we just explain objectively
so the person understands and walks away
what he decides to believe in his dark
basement is his personal
opinion and does not concern science it
concerns religion
and he form and if he forms a club with
other similar
minded people they have a congregation
it's called a religion okay philosophy
what is philosophy well
uh according to these people out there
right
the study of general and fundamental
questions such as those about
existence reason knowledge again
values mind and language i like the fact
that they include existence and
knowledge
knowledge has nothing to do with
anything and now they just believe
when you know something you just believe
it i know something differently
okay and existence is physic has to do
with physics physics is the science of
existence not philosophy
and so again i think this person when
asking you know what are your roots
philosophical roots i think he's
confusing philosophy with physics
it's got nothing to do with philosophy
it's got to do with laying the
foundations of
physics laying the foundations of
physics
is not philosophy for any discipline you
need to lay the foundations
of that discipline okay and for physic
you need to lay the foundations
it's not called philosophy philosophy is
something else philosophy well we'll get
to that in a minute but
let's continue with physics here
knowledge of nature again knowledge has
nothing to do with
science if physics is part of science it
has nothing to do with knowledge
is the natural science okay yeah physics
is part of science but
i don't know about natural what that
really means that studies
matter in motion and behavior through
space and time
and the related entities of energy and
force
now in physics we do not study energy or
force we have energy and force are
mathematical concepts they have nothing
to do with physics
or with science they have to do with
measurement
they have to do with quantification uh
of something they have to do with
equations with um
you know descriptions quantitative
descriptions they have nothing at all
with explaining something
you cannot explain with anything coming
out of math
anything any equation any book ever
written on mathematics
has nothing to do with explanations with
physical
interpretations for that you need
objects and for that you need a
different language
math is a language of quantitative
descriptions
the language you need for that for
explaining physical things
is you can use spanish you can use
english you can use chinese you can use
greek russian whatever you want
it's got to be a language that can
explain qualitatively
you need to explain qualitatively you
need to explain a mechanism
okay and so uh yeah our
physic has nothing to do with energy or
force genuine physics
the one that belongs to science okay has
to do with explaining
some some kind of explaining you gotta
give a physical interpretation
and and then it says the word studies
okay so uh i study i study birds
all day long i didn't learn anything i
can't explain
anything but i studied i studied for the
test and i failed it
so the studying make you a physicist
so again all these definitions are
irrational no one ever bothered to
define these words properly
and so they have these definitions like
oh it's a study
study of what of knowledge or
accumulation of knowledge of what of
energy and force none of that has
anything to do with science with physics
with anything
it's got to do with religion this has
nothing to do with science
okay and i guess the only word that they
hit
there's motion matter in motion
that could be that's as close as they
got to it
okay so um uh
what is philosophy if science is um
or physics is study of physical objects
and
mechanisms explanations of causes
okay what is philosophy well philosophy
ain't philosophy what we've done to this
day known as philosophy
none of that belongs in philosophy
philosophy is a branch of science okay
and philosophy explanations of reasons
and purposes
okay now under philosophy
you have many items today and among them
you have this one
why did someone do something okay that
is included in there
but then you have a lot of descriptions
out there
a lot of opinions recommendations
how to behave in life what to eat that's
my philosophy you know
and so people think that the word
philosophy means any way of thinking
it's your way of thinking it's your
philosophy
we can't use that for anything
in the world that's like saying god is
everything
well yeah great god is everything god is
nothing okay
essentially and this is the same thing
if philosophy is just a way of thinking
and philosophy is nothing
it's garbage and how would you
distinguish yourself from aristotle why
do you call him a philosopher why do you
say
well um aristotle was a greek
philosopher
what are you an english philosopher i
mean you know we're all philosophers if
it's just a way of thinking
so the word philosophy would have no use
whatsoever
if we define it as a way of thinking a
recommendation a belief
we all have belief we all have
recommendations we all have political
philosophies
religious philosophies so those are
that's not philosophy you can't use that
word if you're going to go to university
and you say
what do you study i study philosophy
well hopefully that
subject matter has to be well defined so
we know what
you are if you come out of there with a
philosophy degree you say i'm a
i got a phd in philosophy a doctor
in philosophy okay what are you what did
you learn
and what are you different than anyone
else if philosophy is just a way of
thinking
okay so we need to define it and we
define it as explanations of reasons and
purposes
which is only a small branch of what
philosophy is today today we the word
philosophy includes
everything that you can think of and no
we don't do that in science we have to
give some real meaning to the word
philosophy and we cut it right there we
chop it
they're at explanation of reasons and
purposes
which differs from physics which is
explanations of causes and mechanisms
okay for that uh you know again
philosophy is not equal to the
foundations of physics
okay that's that's not a philosophy that
you need to lay the foundations
of physics to know to understand to
to be able to explain what physics is
about you have to
put limits to to your discipline for
that you have to establish the
foundation you want to be a doctor well
you need to know words such as you know
what is health what is disease etc
you want to be a lawyer you need to know
what law means what punishment means
what you know all the
jail or whatever means uh so you have a
vocabulary
in each discipline in physics you need a
vocabulary as well and for that
you have to establish define those terms
and those are the foundations
of physics that's not philosophy
okay um
so here's the definition of science so
that you can see how this fits in
okay and science is divided into parts
physics
and philosophy okay and the one on the
left
physics deals with objects and explains
causes and mechanisms well the one on
the right
primarily deals with concepts okay or
that's the
bread and butter of philosophy because
you don't really need an object you need
concepts you deal with concepts there
and what you're going to do you're going
to explain reasons and purpose
okay so uh this is
the uh notion of science
and so no it's not uh what this file
said
um what are the uh foundations
of what did he say philosophy natural
philosophy was it
uh it says uh yeah what are your
philosophical roots
and i guess he was referring to you know
um
what kind of opinions or recommendations
you have or whatever
no no science is objective
so we have to define the terms that are
going to underline
our discipline so that we chop it
very crisply this is physics this is
philosophy
those are the two only two branches of
science
and within those two branches you have
sub-branches okay you have
chemistry uh i don't know uh geology
maybe on under physics and a lot of
these are you know have
their aspect of philosophy as well as
you know as uh the physical aspect
and then you have the philosophy on the
other side so
that's it it's very crisp very
straightforward anyone can understand it
you cannot understand science philosophy
or physics under the definitions we have
today
because they never defined these terms
scientifically
they don't know how to define terms
scientifically that's the bottom line
uh this is what science is not okay
here it is so anything that falls on
this
um list is not science what science is
not science we do not
observe okay we kill the observers we do
it mafia style we kill the witness
okay we don't study anybody can study it
doesn't mean he's a scientist
physicist or philosopher for that matter
we don't collect data we don't analyze
data we don't measure
we don't use equations we don't make
calculations describe present
evidence never present evidence in
science
evidence is used to persuade the jury
that's known as religion
you're trying to convince people you're
gonna you're gonna try to change their
minds
you change some of the jurors minds you
don't change all of their
minds and so what do you do with the
ones that didn't change their mind you
say they're not scientists because they
didn't change your
their mind to fit yours
so again all these things you got to
consider you know when you analyze what
is science
okay uh so we don't present evidence we
don't do experiments
why don't we do experiments because
experiments uh if anything have to do
with technology but
if you draw a conclusion from an
experiment just come with your
conclusion with your
theory your explanation don't come with
an experiment
because the only purpose of an
experiment is to use as
evidence to persuade the jury which was
what michael faraday
did in the 1830s he would go in to do a
little test you know
in front of people and people would say
wow look at that magnetism
[Music]
yeah what to convince the jury just to
wow the jury that's all it was for
okay we don't demonstrate again okay
prove seek the truth we don't seek the
truth in science the word truth has to
do
strictly with religion truth means you
believe in something
you have knowledge you have belief you
have the truth keep it
keep it away from me keep your truth far
away from me
we don't know how to persuade convince
convert or recruit people
that's religion okay we don't believe or
no it's our synonym we don't do that
either we don't know
we explain we don't develop technology
we don't invent gadgets we don't grant
prizes
you know you have all these phds
uh walking with their medals oh i've got
a noble medal and he walks down the
aisle you know like a
girl who won the beauty contest with
with her bouquet of roses you know and
she
has these crocodile tree tears
coming out of her eyes no i'm the most
beautiful woman in the world
these guys could go do the same thing
you walk with their medals say oh i'm
the most intelligent
guy on earth my god that's what these
uh so-called scientists have come down
to
they they today they kill for those
medals
i want the medal keep it i can get one
for 10 cents at the store it's not made
of pure gold but it's
gold completed you know maybe so we
don't add grand prizes or win prizes we
do not censor theories we want to hear
as many as possible
explanations hey bring it on defend it
okay so it's the other way around we do
not censor theories
quantum mechanics uh general relativity
strength theory
uh mathematical physics essentially they
uh
fear theories that do not match theirs
and they say well we've proven ours
okay and so if they've proven theirs you
know what are we researching looks like
it looks like we're done
i mean if they've proven it right they
believe in it
they say it's a fact now then they deny
it and say well it's not a fact but we
believe in it all the
scientists in the world raise their
hands you know we all believe in it
okay so it's like uh asking all the
christians to raise their hand
do you believe in god no i do believe in
god okay
have they proven god because they all
raise their hands how about the flat
earthers you know they all raise their
hands so the earth is flat
uh yeah so what they fear the most is
uh losing that censorship capability
okay so we don't vote for theories uh
science is not democratic
this is not a jury trial where you prove
that the jury and the jury raises its
hand says
the defendant is guilty
no no that's not the way we do it in
science science
we present the case and then we leave
the courtroom then we go to church and
that's where we determine if the
defendant is guilty or not guilty
okay uh we don't rely on authority which
is what 99 of humanity does they say oh
the scientists they discovered they
invented they proved we don't do that in
science
science every person is on his own
you got to go out there and you can't
use these guys as a reference
you cannot say oh einstein said that's
authority
is einstein speaking his ghost speaking
through your mouth or what
you got to make up your mind does that
what this guy said
makes sense does it can you rationalize
it
if you cannot rationalize it you're
going to say well einstein said you know
he told me
and and he got a nobel prize and you
can't say that
okay so none of that belongs to science
but this is the circus
in which uh these uh mathematicians turn
science into they turn science into a
circus
it's all uh you know giving prizes
medals
uh voting and saying well you know the
majority believes like this and
is that science or is science look
i'm on my own i don't have anyone we're
all alone in this island it's you and me
kid
and i'm going to explain to you
something so that you understand it
and i can't use the guy behind me
because there is no one behind me we're
all alone on the silence you and me
it's up to you you can't consult anyone
either you gotta
try to make sense of what i said and say
well okay that makes sense and i have a
different theory okay what's your theory
and you have to defend that theory
that's science
but to say well all these scientists
proved and they demonstrated in a lab
and
you can't demonstrate in the lab what uh
experiments
uh something that is invisible
intangible such as light magnetism
gravity you can't do that
the only way you can do it is
rationalizing it
for that you need objects to explain the
mechanism
okay and of course we don't present
witnesses or testify what we do
is we do it mafia style we kill
the witness so he doesn't testify okay
always in science always kill the
witness
take a gun with you to the conference as
soon as someone introduces a witness you
shoot him down
okay tom bill gate he told you
okay uh one file says he insists
he insists on touch okay so he says the
phone he says
let's suppose a man who rotates the
stone tied with a rope then definitely a
stone
hit with the air surrounding it okay so
he's saying that
you have a ball or a stone you
have a rope going around uh because the
ball is going around
and the the rope in this case the string
is hitting
the air that's what he's saying here
okay likewise when
magnetic threads spin his language is
not too great but
we'll we'll work with it uh thread spin
it must be
hit with the electromagnetic rope that
come
out of the magnet okay the first thing i
want to clarify there is no
it's not ropes that come out and swing
okay just in case
it's the thread the the rope opens up
and the threads are the ones that are
swinging
a lot of people don't understand that
they think it's rope swinging no it's
thread swinging takes two threads twine
threads to make a rope
okay so the thread and rope are two
different things
try to keep that in mind a lot of people
don't understand that
they just kind of you know superficially
look at the theory and they
talk about ropes when they should be
talking about threads and vice versa
but you said that magnetic thread not
hit with the electromagnetic rope
exactly goes right through
that come out of magnet because it's not
the definition of object correct
okay definition of object is not that
which you can touch
or see which is what he's talking about
he's talking about hit that's why
underlying hit everywhere
uh you cannot see or touch the rope
okay you can only uh imagine it
you can visualize it you can think about
it
okay and you can explain with it so you
make an assumption
okay an assumption what is an assumption
you make an assumption that
all atoms in the universe are
interconnected by
a rope-like uh entity a dna-like
entity a chain like entity it's
elongated it unites two atoms
okay it's an assumption it's known as an
assumption
what is an assumption is something you
propose in order to
so that the public understands your
theory the theory
founded upon that assumption so you have
an assumption and you have an
explanation
in order to explain you have to begin
with the assumptions you mentioned the
objects you're going to use
you're going to mention the initial
scene what what picture they're
visualizing or maybe you just
make a movie of it or whatever you put
it there and you say okay look at this
movie
and these are the initial scenes these
are my assumptions
and then you go on you make certain
assumptions then you move on to
the theory and your theory has to be
based on those assumptions
the assumption here is that all atoms
are interconnected by
an electromagnetic rope looks more like
this my
my fists here are the atoms and a rope
interconnection
that's the assumption so far i haven't
done anything with it i'm making this
assumption okay
and then i'm saying what is light well
light is a torsion of that rope
uh what is gravity well a bunch of uh
ropes
uh that open up as one object that
drifts towards another etc
you explain the theory the mechanism
okay my point is
when we rotate stone tie with rope then
definitely a stone
hit with the air surrounding it okay
yeah we
saw that i'm assuming that when i rotate
this right
okay there it goes i'm assuming that the
uh string here okay we'll call that the
rope
uh is uh effectively hitting near
the atoms of air or the molecules of air
that are around here
no problem likewise when magnetic
threads spin it must be
hit with a electromagnetic row which
comes out of the magnet
electromagnetic road cannot touch
objects goes right through another rope
another thread
through an atom okay how do i get that
through to you
and why because an object is not that
which has shape
um an object is that which i shape it's
not that which you can touch
or see okay and here's uh
i'm going to put this up again just for
you specifically
so that you can see why you cannot touch
the rope one of the one of the mechanism
there's a couple more but i'm just going
to put this one which i've shown in the
past
okay you have one five fingers and we're
gonna look at one
a single atom of each finger okay so
we're talking about only five atoms
there
they're
colored i think in greenish blue okay so
we have these atoms
and they're moving towards a ball okay
and the ball has all these atoms going
right
that make it up and you have the ropes
that go right through it
and three of those ropes you can see
from three of the fingers
are connected to three atoms on the ball
okay
well the problem here is that the atoms
that in your fingers
they're going right through the rope in
other words like a beat on an abacus
okay so even if the uh
atom uh was made of the same wire as the
abacus
it would be able to touch the wire
itself it would slide through the uh
wire as the wire opens up and builds
up the atom that's going through it okay
the only
thing that an atom in your finger can
touch is another atom and in this case
the atom of the ball
okay so you're sliding your atoms
through
the ropes that make up the atoms
you can't touch the rope itself okay and
so
and you say well how come i can't touch
it you can't touch it because the atom
is made of the same ropes it's sliding
through
and then again the problem that's always
been and the reason you
use the the notion of touch at all times
is that we've always identified objects
with that which you can see and touch
and that's why people uh mathematicians
they talk about going to the lab running
an experiment
because they want to see and touch and
the problem is mother nature's
mediators cannot be seen or touched
okay you can't see the rope you can't
touch the rope you can't see an atom
you can touch an atom but you don't
realize you can't
you can touch a hydrogen atom but
hopefully you can tell me whether you
touched it or not and the answer is no
you can't feel it so you can't see or
touch an atom
okay and uh and so does that mean it's
not there
no you have to make an assumption you
know here i'm breathing something i
can't see the atoms
but i go like that and i feel something
going through my nose something
invisible
what is it a ghost that's going through
my nose no
we make an assumption we say well let's
assume there's a bunch of little balls
there right
in our case all interconnected little
balls right
and they're going through my nose i'm
taking them in with my nose
and so we make an assumption can i see
the the little balls of the oxygen balls
there
nitrogen whatever no i can't see them
they're not there because i can't see
them is is that the definition we're
going to use
see and touch for object and for exist
no we have to make a proper definition
we say an object set which
has shape and existence if we're going
to say that it exists we say that in
addition it has
location and now we can use those words
consistently to explain to someone else
something in a rational manner in a way
that he can understand it
if he's a rational human being okay
okay and a final issue here uh
phil says uh
he says how does the rope torquing light
result in
polarized unpolarized circularly
polarized etc
light how does polarizing filter block
torquing okay so he wants to know about
um the first one you need to understand
which is already a monster okay
without going into circularly polarized
light and some of these other
variations let's just go straight
forward with
polarization light polarization okay
linear polarization
okay so that we understand the mechanism
there okay
and in one of my papers published papers
okay i
had this picture which i bring to you so
that you can see it okay
so that you understand the mechanism
okay and you have the x
y and z on the left and you have the x y
and z on the right
uh the x as you can see the reference at
the bottom
x is polarized light y is the beam
extinction and the z is going to be a 45
degree
polarizer that's inserted between uh
the the two
polarizing films there okay
so let's go with the first one x okay up
on the top
you have unpolarized light that means
light comes in there
uh it's done usually with uh
monochromatic light
light of a single frequency okay single
wavelength
and it goes through this polarizer this
material
okay that polarizes light which we're
going to
illustrate as being vertical so all the
atoms are vertically oriented
okay does the light go through the film
the answer is no the light
from the uh the source is
uh simply an atom that's tied to an atom
of the polarizing film of the film
that's in front of it
of that panel okay so we have one atom
of the source the light source
tied to one atom in the film and
it's going at a certain frequency what
is the atom
in the film doing in the polarizing
material
what it's doing it's relaying that
signal to the polarizer behind it which
is also vertical
so both of these films or
obstacles are vertically oriented their
crystal structure is vertically oriented
so what it does is one film relays the
signal to the atom of the next film
which relays it to the
screen on the back okay so that's
essentially
how unpolarized light works it just goes
straight through
what happens when we turn that polarizer
the one at a
sideways 90 degrees that's what's shown
on why
okay when you put it sideways what
happens is
um suddenly the
light it gets extinguished you don't see
it at the screen
and so the question is why why don't you
see it well according to
quantum mechanics what's happening here
is that
if the light is coming unpolarized to
the first
polarizing film or obstacle when you
turn it around
what you're doing is you're blocking the
horizontal component
of the electromagnetic wave which
typically is the
magnetic field so what these people are
saying is that what goes through is
essentially only the electric field
they're saying that
only the um horizontal component
goes through and and so you're just
going to have
one field you have light that has only
one field no
you don't have an electromagnetic field
you either have electric or magnetic
field
one or the other that's what they're
saying and they say that's what blocks
light
but the the first problem is that there
is no such thing as a transverse
wave and there are no such things as
electric and magnetic
fields there are no such things as waves
or fields
and so this explanation is nonsense okay
what happens when you put a third
polarizer that's at z
on the left still and you put it in
between
a and b and you put it at a 45 degree
angle
well what happens is you begin to
re-establish the beam
okay and so the question is why does the
beam reappear
by putting a polarizing
uh material at a 45 degree angle to the
other two
one which is horizontal the other one at
which is vertical
and on the right you see the answer uh
that's with the rope model
okay and here you can see uh a and b
are both this is x on the right
you see a and b the polarizing uh
material
it's vertical they both have their
crystal structure
oriented vertically okay what happens
when you turn
a sideways well what happens is
uh you change the angle at which the the
light from the source
goes to those atoms and how they are
connected to the ones
on the polarizing film at b that's turn
that
is still vertical okay one is horizontal
uh
the crystal structure the other one has
the crystal structure
vertically and that's why you block the
beam what happens when you insert a
third polarizer c uh in between
at 45 degree angles and i'm talking
about z on the right
uh well what happens is you begin to
re-establish the beam because again
you are bringing back the um
the rope uh to where it was
originally okay and
again a picture's worth a thousand words
uh
but a video is worth a billion and so
i made a little device which i showed at
the
our conference in argentina and
it consists of this very crude but it
explains the mechanism
and right now we're just looking at the
mechanism so that you understand it
okay so here we have the polarizers okay
and i'm looking at the polarizers
sideways the ropes
obviously represent light okay so what
happens when the
when pulled when the beam comes through
and light is
unpolarized well it shows up at the
screen
you know behind uh one of these
polarizers
okay and so it just goes straight
through because one polarizer
okay is vertical the other one's
vertical their atoms are interconnected
okay and light essentially goes through
uh from the source
to the first polarizer which i'll call
this one here okay
and it goes through straight ahead to
the other polarizer
this one here okay goes right through
and what it's doing the first polarizer
is
relaying the same signal to the atom
it's connected to
on the second polarizer what happens
when you turn one of the polarizers
around okay and so that's what we're
going to do we're going to turn this one
around let's do this one instead
so ah this way now what happens to the
ropes
you can see now something's changed okay
the the angles changed of the ropes
and uh i have a third one here but i
need a third hand to do it but
uh essentially let's see if i can do it
this way i think i can do it that way
uh if you change this one you can see
the ropes uh coming
back into where they were okay so
the the angle is not as in other words
you can see why
a polarizer slowly gradually
extinguishes the beam here okay uh you
know when you have
um i do have it but i didn't prepare to
show it but if you take
two polarizing lenses and you
you turn them around with respect to
each other you'll see that the beam
slowly extinguishes itself and here you
can see why
okay from a physical standpoint at least
our explanation with ropes
if you turn that second winner yeah if
you turn that second one at a 45 degree
angle
the ropes are not quite what they were
before which was
you know completely like this okay
they're not completely uh
screwed up they're they're at this angle
at a lesser angle
okay and so the more you twist it uh
just one polarizer with respect to the
other the more the
beam becomes extinguished or less
extinguished
that's in general terms the mechanism
there's more involved because remember
when you're doing this you're also
twisting each one of the ropes in other
words you're giving it a different angle
okay so there's more involves a lot more
complicated than that
before you can get to circularly
polarized light
please try to understand the mechanism
of
linearly polarized light okay
and with it i'll see you next time which
is what on wednesday
bye